hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to spooky's house of
jump skiers we have keys and even though
i was just playing this a little bit
earlier i've already forgotten what i
was doing
the garden i remember isn't there
another whoa
that's way faster than i remember it
being and i'm gonna knock over my water
and i'm not gonna do that so there's
another side of the garden and the clown
i'd forgotten about the clown
oh good that's where the keys were too
oh good gl labs um
oh good
hell gate source
spirit seal
escape tram
oh
okay all right
just another thursday
all
right
in memory of doug jail labs associate oh
sorry doug hope you uh
died well congratulations doug glabs has
chosen you to volunteer for a special
assignment we are sending you deep into
the earth to excavate the area of our
new department look out for ghosts and
skeletons down there good luck
[Music]
what
[Music]
oh what
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
okay
oh i need to kill them
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh my god i have a gun
i didn't know i had a gun since when did
i have a gun
okay anyway um i'm good with that i
don't need to play that i don't need to
do that i don't need to do any of that
after all our research and
experimentation we were looking in the
wrong place the dolls did little but
distract us they could not fill my heart
and they were not suitable for you to
inhabit that is why you do not come back
to me but now i found something else a
relic from the old kingdom era that
seals spirits to the earth though it
originally was used for great evil i
will use it for you something tells me
that's not going to be good
something tells me that's how things go
horribly wrong
something tells me that's kind of bad
live laugh love oh yeah
good
log 32 we abandoned the doll idea of
tethering the subject to a physical
object and instead we sealed her spirit
within the mansion itself her abilities
within the facility should be incredible
the director would be pleased with the
outcome of his sacrifice
of his sacrifice you say
are you trying to tell me that this is
the lore of spooky spooky herself
oh yeah express yourself
oh yeah oh yeah hopefully now that the
doll project is over i'll get
transferred back to the surface facility
soon it's been very interesting but i
generally fear for my life every day
that's not ideal job security
yeah i know it don't sound like it
don't sound like it none at all
oh big oh big room
oh big room
escape trim can i please get on the
escape tram i really don't know how i
got here in the first place
that i do not know
okay good
what was that
you want to run that by me again you
wanna say that one more time to me
you wanna say that to my face
that's what i thought
i thought i heard something
okay bye doll i'll be back
just
oh no
root cellar
oh no oh no
oh no
oh no what are you
it's a black candle no joke
okay
all right this is great
this is great
this is great
hi
may i get out
oh no i'm not out at all
oh no i'm not out at all
oh god
why don't you just be noisier why don't
you
no man i really didn't want to go to the
root cellar
oh
down i don't want to go down
metal plate over an air hole looks like
in slideshow moving into place yeah okay
let's show
[Music]
metal pinwheel piece
let's hope i sealed some ancient evil in
and
nada sealed something in here with me
that's a dog barking
nervous for a second there
okay please hello hi oh that's useful oh
oh good more cages oh good oh oh good
oh good
oh good
oh good
oh big black candle
okay
[Music]
hi
lifeside doll hangs there by several
silver hooks there's a metal pinwheel
please glued to them tear it off
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay well this is normal
okay that's fine
okay
okay
i'm a little turned around
oh
that's okay
and i'm out here
great i got the metal pinwheels
i know exactly why i have those
i definitely would not know why i have
those
of course i have those
[Music]
these spirits get so temperamental we
keep having to perform rituals to keep
them in check when they act out it's
necessary to inflict pressure on the
husk inhabited by the spirit don't
forget that these dolls are not real
people
yeah but i thought that wasn't that the
point
wasn't that the whole point
so you're trying to bring people back
from the dead and therefore you know you
might want to treat them a little nicely
wasn't that the whole point
oh hi oh great it's some sort of strange
sculpture
yeah
oh yeah
that's a sculpture all right
oh yeah
definitely not someone's back
it's locked i need more pinwheel it's
where i got the first pinwheel piece
okay so these two rooms i got the
pinwheel pieces so it must be one of the
rooms ahead unless it was something to
do with that other big cavernous room
because there did seem to be more in
there like i don't know what those
picture frames were all about but they
must have been something right
okay yeah like what are you about
i don't even remember seeing you here
before
what are you about
do you think that doll's mad at me
hey you mad at me
you mad at me
oh oh
oh i'm gonna get out of here i don't
like this place
i don't like it none
oh
okay definitely not in there we know for
sure we've confirmed it we've absolutely
confirmed that okay there was this room
here
oh yeah it's you the back yeah
some sort of strange sculpture yeah
oh
i forgot i had an axe
[Music]
i forgot i had an axe
okay i unlocked it i'm out of here
i'm not out of here
i'm not out of here at all
[Music]
okay
glad i went through all that trouble to
get into this place
which seems to be a dead end
well if i had something with which to
light the
this desk wasn't here before
okay but i got the key card good i'll
get out of here
all right later everybody i'm on my way
out of here
oh come after me
everything's fine
everything's fine
[Music]
it's fine just a beep i'm out here i'm
outta here i'm out of here don't come at
me don't come at me i've got the next
i'll kill you
i'll kill you
i don't like this
oh
okay
ah
okay we're fine everything's good
easy
[Laughter]
no trouble at all
what
oh no
oh my god
i didn't expect you to be in front of me
i expected you to be anywhere but in
front of me where's my sweet baby doll
what did you do with my sword
get away
i thought you all were dead
oh god held shut by
oh god
oh god
yeah it's being held shut all right
oh god okay yep goodbye
the fingers cut apart
they sure did they sure did
just that easy huh just that easy
okay well that was a nice side track
i'm glad that i got detoured there oh
hey bud oh doll no oh
don't do that to me no don't do that to
me it's okay
oh don't do that to me are you just sad
because i left you for a while
don't be sad
oh escape tram
well
no map of area really
okay i'm just willing to bet that i
don't have what i need
it goes all the way back to the surface
start the train
oh oh
oh this can't be right no this can't be
right
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh no
oh
okay i'm dead to the dead take to the
dead to the dead to the take to the dead
to the dead to take the dead to take the
dead dead then take the dead
i need some
i do i do need some milk i do
all right so that was a trap i should
have known like i should have known all
right but my sweet baby boy
let's see cut those off
my sweet baboo
my sweet baboo baloo
hey my sweet baboobo
please don't tell me that there are
freaking
there's a freaking clown nearby that's
the last thing i would like to know
about there there cannot be a clown
that's all i gotta say there really
can't be a clown if there's a clown i'm
gonna have so much trouble
oh boy oh i know where the black candles
are
should i grab those on my way down keira
genesis is just about fried we've
summoned far too many spirits for it to
handle even returning them might
collapse the gate so i moved three of
the ritual candles into the root cellar
that should deter any more summoning for
now spooky will probably order someone
to go get them but that's not my problem
and odds are they wouldn't survive down
there anyway well how did you get down
there
how'd you get down there to move them
doll spirit interference place outside
room
yeah you right
that's what cure is all about
okay well i don't want to go get the
candles why would i want to do that
why would i want to do that
why would i want that
the answer is i don't want that
yeah you right you're right you're right
okay well now i know what it wants me to
do but i don't necessarily want to do it
ah the hell gate oh the hell gate we
love the hell gate
the spirit seal is over here apparently
oh hi oh hey
i don't like it here
you should probably just leave
okay
there's nothing for you here oh
um okay
oh wow
oh
the seal is almost complete and then you
can return to me it requires a nightmare
to work so i will surrender mine the
same nightmare that took you from us
will not bring you back
okay
the seal can be turned off but if i do
this i'll have to let go of the let the
doll spirit go there's no going back
after this erase the nightmare
no because i don't know wait what am i
doing
i don't know what i'm doing
why would i be able to make a choice
here when i don't know what the choice
is
okay
so thinking about it logically it wants
me to erase a nightmare the nightmare
being the house itself i am the father
of the
spooky
i am spooky's father okay but if i were
to say go back to the root cellar and
grab all the candles to be able to do
the ritual then in all honesty probably
the good ending is actually
just erasing the nightmare in the first
place but the truth would not be
revealed
because i need to know what the truth is
so i need to go down to the root cellar
and hopefully i can have tea time with
the doll and that'll make the doll a
little less
tearful
okay let's go let's come on it's okay
it's okay
it's okay tea time
tea time
tea time
tea time
it's tea time time for tea
don't you feel so full of glee when you
sit down
here with me
are those nooses on the teapot ah
everything's great as you can see
i am filled with such glee oh my god i
have to pee
i'm getting up okay i need to go to the
root cellar
not today not today not today you and me
we're gonna go down to the root cellar
okay dolly
okay dolly it's gonna be fine
everything's gonna be just fine
all right so i remember what
oh my god
okay
okay
oh my god
what's happening i could bro i could see
her in the corner of my eye with any
vision beyond that she twitches and
moves towards me sometimes i can hear
her breathing
behind me how did i get here is this our
punishment for for denying death i've
only ever followed orders my blind
devotion brought me here perhaps
blindness can't get me out as well
blindness
is that a hint oh god please no oh god
oh blah
oh ho ho hey hey hey hey okay y'all
please i need your love
okay i don't really remember where i am
none of this seems very familiar maybe
this was a terrible mistake this seems
like it was actually a terrible mistake
i see you over there i see you
i see you
there was one over here i remember that
whoo
there was one in here i know there was
oh my god please no
yeah okay got the ritual candle okay
that's one
whoa hey hey easy there
oh god okay that's fine
it's fine stop
doing that
stop it stop it no
here
i remember
i remember
i remember
missed me
and one more
that's right there okay got it i have
all three
i've got all three there are only three
missing
yep
miss me by that much yeah dully i know
you're a little scared but it's okay
everything's just fine was it here
i don't remember which one was leading
up okay this one no it was not that one
so it was over here by the pinwheel door
so it was somewhere in here
wasn't it
how do i get how did i get in here
wasn't it the pinwheel door
wasn't that the whole point
oh god
no there was some kind of key card
there's a key card right
ow okay ow ow ow please give me your
give me your spirit
there was a key card door here somewhere
here here
okay
great
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god okay
where am i
[Music]
oh this is not right
oh interesting
interesting
interesting interesting okay let's take
a little tea break ow
oh your spirit was fine oh man okay so
i'm gonna save
i'm gonna do what's only logical
oh god hey how you doing so uh
yeah let's see what happens when i try
the candles okay let's try this let's
see what happens
there we go
perfect
let's see what happens
any further spear returns will result in
hell gate
collapse okay
oh my god
active description puppet
active description dear like
active description ghost
spirit is already active led back to
hell gate source to return
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
what am i doing i can't see
oh my god okay i'm going to leave oh my
god
do that do the thing hellgate
oh i'm dead
[Music]
i don't know what i did
everything goes dark you know it really
does
i don't know what i did i don't know if
i was supposed to try to fight that
or what but that did not go good
uh so that summoning was um bad but you
know maybe that's uh my punishment i i
don't know i'm gonna try that again am i
supposed to have a key to the hell gate
am i supposed to be able to go into the
next room because i got a key or
something is that what it wants for me a
key raw
all right let's go for you buddy spirit
already active lead back to hell gate
source to return
okay all right okay
ah good
oh i see what we're doing now i see what
we're doing now i see what we're doing
now
i see what's going on
oh boy oh no
oh no
what oh my god hey what's up pal
hey okay
[Applause]
oh hi dear
wham not today
again i'm not exactly sure how many of
these
get out of here get away from me
you'll never get me
yeah i don't know how many of these i'm
supposed to go through but if it's
anything like spooky's was it's gonna be
like a hundred
i don't know if there's any way out of
this
it might just be an eternity in this
hell escape
what oh god what the frick
what
what
oh what
what
oh what
what
[Applause]
oh no
oh my oh my
oh my
oh my
whoa
i did it
[Music]
praise be a morgantoth
interesting
thank you why are you crying there pup
why are you why are you crying
should i save i feel like i should save
i feel like i did something uh worthy of
a save
i saved and i can't tell anybody
otherwise
oh yeah she's crying she's not too happy
by the way that's enough for uh today
unless i just screwed up something
horribly by saving there but i won't
know so don't tell me so thank you
everybody so much for watching i'm gonna
play more of this soon and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]